i i finally saw it last night at 2 30 in
the morning spoiler alert fast forward
to the next five minutes yeah because we
will talk about it do they they get to
the wrong face forward and we're just
like yeah and then armand died
oh no
[ __ ]
i mean if you haven't watched it already
what are you doing came out two [ __ ]
days ago what are you like some [ __ ]
nurse something or like frontline worker
yeah dealing with like some like weird
illness going around
nerd nerd yeah though isn't it yeah it
was i was i liked the ending some people
didn't i don't know why oh i didn't like
that um
what's his face and and
what's her face got back together nice
that she went back to him yeah i didn't
like that it's kind of the point it's
like
i saw someone had a good take on that
that the powers that be are so
exhausting that you just give in you
forego your integrity and you just
[ __ ] fold yeah you just accept yeah
someone was like yeah just rich people
always went and i was like damn
i guess that is kind of
what it's about like the old lady she
just
ices that chick at the end she's like
yeah i'm just sobbing remember how i
sprung you along for six days remember
how you thought that you were gonna get
out of this hell hole of a hotel like
dangle that over your head for you can
run your own business yeah you can be
your own boss [ __ ] it psych
armond went out he he
quit his job the way we all would hope
to quit our jobs eating ass
no
hi
yeah high as hell taking a [ __ ] on a
customer's clothes and then dying
in the most expensive room in the hotel
that really is the ultimate way to quit
yeah getting murdered
hard as well fight hard as hell you will
not be forgotten in that you can't fire
me i quit yeah
well no what the [ __ ] are you doing yeah
pass out yeah bathtub yeah later later
the grim part about that is
you know buddy got away with it he
probably just worked it out in his head
like well he he came into my room so
whatever yeah he just i can hate that
guy yeah god his character was
insufferable yeah dude like every time
he you know was going in on the uh
armand or whatever
i was just like just [ __ ] drop it
dude and when his wife was like you're
the baby dude
got him coddled by your mom
she can't she comes on our honeymoon
like you you can't stop your tantrum
that you got the wrong room yeah you're
the baby and i was like yes [ __ ]
right all the characters are pretty and
self-insufferable but um
i like the dad
he's just a [ __ ] goofball yeah he's
an idiot yeah getting punched in the
[ __ ] thing yeah i like how that's
what it took for his wife to sleep with
him yeah
getting socked in the face
and she's like fine
i'll let you have some sex yeah that
[ __ ] when he's like hitting on those
young girls at the bar and it's so
awkward it's so [ __ ] weird man when
shane was swimming over to the girls and
hitting on them oh it's like that was
[ __ ] and then his wife just like
leaves yeah uncomfortable you left why'd
you leave i'm finally glad we got like
some payoff you know the whole season
the music everything makes you just want
to like be like when are we going to get
this release when we get this release
finally bust this nut
let it go and finally we were able to
climax i feel that we we've seen
everything in tv it all just came back
to what about six people talking yeah
yep
and that got everyone they're all people
you have like kind of seen somewhere and
you're like oh yeah
i hate that person yeah especially on
vacation i recently like when we went to
hawaii
i heard this dude
behind me having a conversation with
this lady
and he was a more dialed back version of
shane and he's just like
oh like where are you from oh yeah yeah
you know what a good friend of mine owns
a winery up there yeah and he you know
you know what i'm gonna i'm gonna send
him a text message right now it's like a
30 year old dude talking about how he's
so connected with these people that own
wineries and these bottles that they
make and all these brands of wine and
this older lady just like oh yeah i love
drinking
and i love drinking in the morning yeah
yeah and what he's just like gaming her
up
not for any other reason than to just be
like yeah i'm that [ __ ] dude yeah i
just so badly want to turn around and be
like both of you shut the [ __ ] up and
eat your eggs then go to the beach and
just don't talk ever again that's the
thing about these shows now they're so
real it's like they get you thinking
it's like which one am i
am i [ __ ] yeah you know it makes you
think about yourself a little bit who do
you think you were in there
the sun
yeah
just watching porn on the beach yeah
just fantasizing over rowing a boat yeah
for whatever i want to live
just want to go on a hanukkah or
whatever yeah
[Laughter]
what is it that transition where he was
like watching porn on the beach and then
it's just like a bunch of shirtless
dudes coming off the beach i was like
and he just talked to his dad about
being gay i'm like what are they saying
here i'm like oh he just wants to row
the canoe
in a gay way though yeah in a gay way
yeah no i was the one getting his ass
eaten
you guys have the same haircut
that was the kid that went super viral
during quarantine for doing that zoom
audition when the director was talking
[ __ ] and he was like oh yo i can hear
you oh what that was the same guy
wow and i was with matt
this weekend yeah yeah and uh he was
like yeah my friends
right you torment yeah my friends are
friends with them and we facetimed them
to ask him a while about why lotus and
he was like so was he in there like did
he really get in there
he was like i don't really remember
honestly
oh like if that dude actually put his
nose in his butt yeah yeah or put some
tongue in there he doesn't really seem
to
who knows maybe they just like actually
laid out some coke they're like all
right uh we'll we'll come film
eventually but we want it to feel
natural yeah we want you guys to get in
the moment just do what you you don't
have to
do these lines but you know
they're just gonna be there
do your thing do your thing we're gonna
let you just chill for 15 minutes and if
you find it there's a little k in this
room so you know
have have a party yeah
have fun the producers are like
i put the k and everything yeah
it's everywhere
they come in and they're already
they're already eating ass yeah it's
like perfect we didn't didn't even have
to tell them they're eating ass none of
the gears in there they're just like
going at it everyone's like backing each
other up just surrounding them yeah
makeup comes in do you want me to doll
anything up and armon's just still
eating butt
the whole time
[Laughter]
it's such a mad thing to do to be like
yo i'm gonna facetime that kid yeah yo
did you feel that guy's like tongue in
your ass so was his nose like
in your [ __ ] yeah i don't know yeah i
can't remember oh yeah
could you let a
for like a s
you know a breakout roll like that could
you take some tongue in your ass yeah it
didn't take real tongue
but a nose
what
it was really quick because i would love
to do a show like that yeah but
they're like yeah a guy's face has to be
in your butt for a little bit i'd be
like yeah for the show
for that pivotal moment that everyone's
gonna be talking about [ __ ] yeah yeah i
if i got cast for that i'd be hitting
squats like crazy
i'd be making sure the back side of my
legs look ripped
well people remember that [ __ ] like
absurdly ripped armond ate that guy's
ass out that guy's ass was [ __ ] yo
how did he eat how did he even get
between those
i'm certain his nose is getting crushed
in there
i'm surprised his head didn't pop like a
[ __ ] water balloon
imagine the kid just goes overboard in
the scene like all right just you know
face the desk and you guys want to
improv a little bit cool camera goes
through the door he reaches back grabs
the dudes he's like yeah you [ __ ]
like that you like that [ __ ] mud pie
how's that [ __ ] taste [ __ ]
cut jesus christ what's up
[Laughter]
jesus
i think it's in my teeth i think i've
got some pubes in me too like a hot dog
in there are those buns
huh meat stick tell me about it
she says
[ __ ] hell
speaking getting my ass ate
i did some stand up this weekend